Archon is the first of its kind. It's an
open- source AI agent that builds other
AI agents, and I used it to create
something pretty insane that I'm going
to show you right now. I'm calling
Archon the world's first agent here, cuz
I really haven't seen anything like it
before. It builds AI agents with pure
code, so you're not tied to a specific
platform. and it uses advanced agentic
techniques under the hood when it's
building these agents on the fly. So,
you get much better results compared to
the generalist AI coding assistants. I
have been working constantly on Archon
the last couple of months, and not only
is it shaping up to be an incredible AI
agent builder for you to use and learn
from, but I have already made a bunch of
impressive agents with it. And there's
one in particular that I cannot wait to
showcase to you right now because I used
Archon to build an AI agent army. It's a
bunch of specialized sub agents that are
each leveraging an MCP server so that my
primary agent can be connected to a
bunch of different services super
easily. It's the beginning of the
ultimate personal assistant. And the
best part is I didn't even have to code
it myself. So, it really shows the power
of Archon. And even this agent is worthy
of its own video. So, allow me to show
you this AI agent army which you can use
right now. And then, as a bonus, I'll
show you how I was able to build it with
Archon. really exciting stuff. So, let's
dive right into it. So, here is the
GitHub repo for Archon, which I'll link
to in the description of this video.
Archon is the mastermind behind
everything that I'm about to show you.
And I use it to build all of my AI
agents now because it is the AI agent
that builds other agents or an agenteer
as I like to call it. And there are two
reasons why I'm building this as a
completely free and open- source tool
for you. The first one is that I'm doing
what they call build in public where I
build archon in iterations sharing my
journey with you as I build this
powerful tool. So it's not like archon
is this productionready thing right now.
It's experimental. I'm still working on
it but you get to come alongside the
journey with me and even contribute if
you want. And then the other reason is
it's an educational framework. I'm using
Archon as a way to teach you more
advanced agentic concepts using my
favorite Python AI frameworks like
Pyantic AI and Langraph. So that's
Archon as a whole and there's
instructions for installing and running
this yourself in this readme if you want
to use it for yourself. But right now
what I want to do is share with you the
AI agent army that I built with MCP
servers that I built with Archon. We'll
play around with it and then later I'll
dive more into Archon and the future
changes that I have for it. And as I
already alluded to, I've already built a
lot of impressive AI agents with Archon.
So, I've got this folder with all of the
best agents that I've been working on.
Right now, we're going to focus on the
MCP agent army. And by the way, if
you're curious about how I built any of
these other agents. If any of these
names peique your interest, check out
dynamis.ai. It's an exclusive community
that I'm starting. The wait list is open
for it now. And I'm going to be having a
lot of live sessions, these workshops
where I'll go into how I built all of
these agents so you can use them for
yourself. But anyway, right now we're
going to be focusing on the MCP agent
army. So I've got this open. Let's bring
this into an IDE. I'll show you the code
really quick and then we'll see how
powerful it is. So all of the code that
you're looking at right here, I did not
write myself. I used archon to make
everything and I did have to iterate a
few times as you usually have to do with
AI coding assistance. But it's just
awesome that after just a few tries,
this is all working and I didn't have to
code it at all. And so I have this
GitHub repo available for you to
download just like Archon if you want to
run this yourself. Hook in your own MCP
servers. I'll show you how to do that
later as well. I even have the original
prompt that I used to kick off the build
with Archon. then a read me with
instructions on how to set up everything
yourself. And I cover why we're doing it
this way anyway because the first big
question is why set up specialized
agents? Why not just give all of these
MCP tools to a single agent? And the
reason for that is specialized agents
are powerful because LLMs get
overwhelmed very quickly if you give
them too many tools because every single
tool is just increasing the length of
the prompt to the LLM. And so if you
split up the burden of the different
tools between different specialized
agents, that means all your prompts are
smaller. The LLMs are going to get
overwhelmed less and you just have to
have one primary agent that can dish out
the requests depending on which MCP
server needs to be used. And so if you
ask it to search the web, the primary
agent will be like, "Oh yeah, I need to
use the Brave MCP server." So it'll just
call the Brave sub agent that will then
figure out which tool to use in the
Brave MCP server. So, I hope that makes
sense. I'll cover in a little bit
exactly how everything is set up here,
but first I want to show you how
powerful this is really quick. So, I
have a version of this which I turned
into an API endpoint. You can see right
here in the studio integration version
folder. So, I've got this running in the
terminal as an API endpoint and I have
that hooked into my agent zero
application which I've covered on my
channel previously. It's a way for you
to connect any local agent into a front
end. So, we have full chat and
conversation history. And so right off
the bat, I can ask it a simple question
that will use one of our sub aents. So I
can say, what GitHub repos do I have?
And then usually it asks for my GitHub
username. So I'll say my username is
colam0000. So I'll send in this request,
go back over to my terminal, and you can
see that it decides to call the GitHub
agent with the query list all
repositories for the username colam0000.
And so it'll take a little bit to make
that request and come back with all my
repos. So I'll come back once that is
done. And boom, there we go. All of my
GitHub repos listed. We've got Archon,
the AI agents, masterclass, automator
agents, local AI package. I don't want
to keep scrolling because it lists my
private repos as well. But yeah, this is
working great. The primary agent new to
route the request to the GitHub sub
agent that uses all the tools from the
GitHub MCP server. And so now I'm going
to go ahead and start a new
conversation. Let's ask it something a
lot more complex that will force it to
use multiple specialized agents within
one request because I want it to search
the web for top AI agent frameworks. And
then what I wanted to do is go into the
frameworks table that I have in my AI
research base and add each of these with
a source where it found that information
from the search as well. So I'm going to
go ahead and send in this request. And
the first thing that it'll do is it'll
send a request to Brave. There we go.
top AI agent frameworks for 2025. And so
I'll let that run. And then after we'll
want it to call into the Air Table sub
agent. And yep, there we go. We got a
result. We got Langchain, OpenAI Swarm.
I don't know if I agree with all of
these in this list, but yeah, it
searched the web for me. It did what it
was supposed to do. And I could be more
specific if I wanted to do a deeper
search as well, obviously. And so now
it's calling the Air Table agent to list
all the entries that are available in
the framework table. So, first it wants
to decide what's here already, which
it's going to get nothing back. And then
it'll end up calling for each of those
10 records to add them in for these
frameworks. And so, I'll pause and come
back once it has completed that request
in full. And there we go. It added all
the records to Air Table, we can see the
calls to the sub agent in the terminal.
And going into Air Table itself, we've
got these 10 records. It's missing
Pantic AI. So, not the perfect list, but
I mean, it's all opinion anyway. It did
a good job researching that for me. And
so now I can ask it to continue. I can
have it use yet another specialized
agent to continue the conversation
because I can say, "Okay, great. Now get
the exact URL for the Air Table base for
AI research and send a link to that in
the research channel in Slack." All
right. So now continuing the
conversation, it has to pick up where it
left off, get that link using the Air
Table sub agent, unless it fetched it
already in a tool, and then send me that
message in Slack right here. So let's
see if it can do that. So I'm going to
give it a little bit of time. It's
thinking about it. See, let's actually
see the terminal here. Um, yep. All
right, calling Air Table and calling the
Slack agent. All right, so let's go into
Slack. And there we go. Yep, we got our
table and I can open this link and boom,
we're in. We got our list up in a new
tab here. So this is working perfect.
It's using all these different sub aents
in tandem to do some really neat things,
kind of like a personal assistant would
do for us. The sponsor of today's video
is Vectorize, and I'm excited to bring
them to you today because they're
solving a huge painoint for AI
solutions. Cuz here's the thing, most AI
agents rely on rag to bring external
knowledge into the fold so they have
access to your documents. But the
hardest part about implementing rag is
just processing your data. getting your
documents in something like Google Drive
formatted in the way where you can store
it in your vector database, something
like Superbase or Pine Cone. This data
processing is called a rag pipeline. And
you've seen these before in N8
workflows, custom code. It's always
complicated, especially when you have to
work with a bunch of different file
types. But look at how simple this is in
Vectoriz. In just four steps, we create
a full rag pipeline that's going to be
constantly waiting for files that are
updated or created within all these
different sources that you can select
here. And then we have a step to extract
the text, a step to embed it to prep it
for the vector database. And then
finally, the step to insert it. And this
supports a bunch of different vector
databases as well like Pine Cone,
Weevate, Superbase. They're all
available to you. It's so easy to
configure this in just minutes. Plus,
they have this rag sandbox where you can
chat with an AI agent using this
knowledge base like I did right here.
Got the current version of Archon
perfectly. You can connect this with an
API to N8N or your custom Python agents.
There's so much control that you have
with this bringing it into your own
projects. And the other thing I want to
show you really quick is you can upload
your documents and it'll recommend the
configurations for your rag pipeline
based on automated testing it does. So,
it really just takes your rag pipelines
to the next level. So, I'll have a link
in the description to Vectorize. I
definitely recommend checking them out
if you want to take all of the unknowns
out of ingesting your data for rag. So,
I hope that that quickly showed you how
powerful this MCP AI agent army is. And
now I want to show you how I built it
with Archon, how everything's set up,
and also how you can extend this to add
any MCP server that you want. because
this really can be a template for your
personal assistant. You can use MCP to
connect to any of your different
services. And having this specialized
agent setup means that you can add 10,
12, 15, 20 MCP servers and you're not
going to overwhelm your system. And so
the way that this is all set up is using
the new MCP integration that my favorite
AI agent framework, Pyantic AI, released
recently. So they have details on this
in their documentation, which I'll link
to in the description of this video.
This is what I fed into Archon because
Archon ingests all the documentation for
Pyanki AI. So I use this to understand
how to build what I'm about to show you
because with this new integration, it is
this easy to set up an MCP server
connection that you can use in your
Pantic AI agents. And so the config will
look very similar to your config with
something like Cloud Desktop or Windsurf
or Cursor as well. So we set up all the
servers like Brave and Air Table. We
have the file system access access to
GitHub to Slack like we saw earlier and
then also firecrawl to scrape individual
pages and then we just create an agent
for each of these. So we have our air
table agent where we just give it the
model we want to use. I'm actually using
GPT4 mini in this case. And so with that
demo that you just saw, it wasn't even
that powerful of an LLM. It was still
able to do things really well. And then
we have our system prompt and then this
new parameter that Pantic AI released
where we can pass in a list of MCP
servers that we want to connect for the
tools for the agent. And so in this case
for each of these sub agents we're just
giving it a single tool so that it's
specialized for using that MCP server.
And then for our primary agent again we
just give it the model and then the
system prompt. And then we have a tool
defined for each of the sub aents that
it can call into. And so it uses this
dock string to understand when and how
to use each of the sub aents. And so if
we have a request that goes in for it to
search the web, it'll be like, oh yeah,
okay, I should use the Brave MCP server
through that sub aent. And so it'll pass
on the request to be handled by the
Brave agent specifically. And so having
all the sub aents handle the individual
tools in the MCP server releases that
burden from the primary agent. So now it
only has to worry about which agent to
call on, not which specific tool. So
instead of having to pick from 30
different tools, it only has to pick
from six different agents. You can see
how that releases the burden, decreases
the size of the prompts overall. And
this is all using pretty basic pideantic
AI code. And so take this for yourself
and set this up for whatever MCP servers
you want because you can just go to the
configuration guide for any MCP server
in GitHub or wherever you find that
server and you can just copy that to set
up that config here. So you define the
server, you define a sub agent and then
you just have to define a tool for the
primary agent to use that sub aent. That
is all it takes for you to hook in any
sub agent that you want. And of course
Archon can help you with that as well.
You could give this as a starting point
to Archon, like just copy this code,
paste it into Archon and say, "Hey, I
want you to now add the Quadrant MCP
server, for example, for Rag." And I
even have the prompt available in this
GitHub repo. This shows you the exact
prompt I use to kick off the AI agent
process with Archon. So, you can take
this prompt, you can copy it, and you
can set up Archon just following the
instructions in the readme, and then you
can dump it right away in the chat, or
you can set this up as an MCP server to
use in an AI IDE like Windsurf or Cursor
and have it create the code for you that
way, too. And so, I already have this
conversation up. It's just an old one
that I want to show you because it did a
good job even after the first request.
It didn't quite oneshot this whole
setup, as I said earlier, but it still
had a really amazing starting point. And
so yeah, this is the same prompt that I
had in that text file. And then this is
what it produced after the first try
where it sets up all of these MCP
servers. It doesn't have the command
quite right for each of these MCP
servers. That's one of the things that I
had to correct, but it had a really good
starting point hooking in all these
individual agents with the different
environment variables for all the MCP
servers. It got that part right. And
then it created the primary agent that
has a dependency for each of its sub
agents. So yeah, working really, really
well. And so yeah, it defines the tools
for each of the sub agents to call into
pretty much what we saw in the Python
script that I showed you earlier, but we
just had to refine it through a couple
of iterations. And so that's what I did
throughout this conversation. I mean, it
got kind of long, but yeah, it didn't
take that long overall. And this kind of
thing is not super easy to set up in a
generalist AI IDE. Like if you were to
try this exact same thing in Windsurf or
Cursor, you would not get nearly as good
of results because just the way that
Archon is able to work with the
documentation for Padantic AI and refine
itself. There's a whole agentic flow
under the hood that I'll show you in a
second here that makes it possible to
produce something like this that isn't
going to be perfect right away, but it
felt pretty close this time. And so I've
just had a blast building things with
Archon, especially this AI agent army.
This is just something that I feel like
is a really good template to take going
forward whenever you want to connect MCP
servers to your custom AI agents. So,
back over to Archon to finish things off
cuz I want to show you how I built
Archon in a way where it could build
that MCP AI agent army and I want to
share some upcoming features for Archon
that are super exciting too. So, the
first thing is I implemented version six
for Archon recently which is a tool
library and MCP integration. And so now
we have all of these pre-built tools,
examples, and MCP servers that are all
within this agent resources folder. And
I have this new agent in the whole
process for Archon that based on the
user's request, it'll actually pick
different examples to give to the
primary coder. So it'll say like, oh
yeah, I need to develop an MCP agent.
Well, let me look at this example and
I'll figure out based on this along with
the podantic AI documentation how to
make that happen. And then we also have
the MCPS folder which gives the config
for a lot of different servers like the
ones we were using for our AI agent
army. And I definitely want to add a lot
more later as well. But yeah, in each of
these JSON files, we have the config for
that MCP server. So Archon will take
this and figure out how to format it for
what we need for Pyantic AI for that
integration. And then we also have
pre-built tools as well. So that if we
don't want to use MCP servers, if you
want something faster or if we just want
custom tools that aren't in MCP servers,
then we can implement the tools right
like this as functions. Just kind of the
classic way to build tools for our
agents. And so those are all the
resources now. And I want to keep adding
more and more. It's kind of just a
version one list of resources and MCP
servers. But if I scroll all the way
down to the graph for Archon, we have
this new agent added. This is the
advisor. So this is what intelligently
picks the examples, pre-built tools and
MCP servers and it feeds that into the
primary coder agent and that all depends
on exactly what the user is asking for.
And so we have quite a few agents now in
this whole process for Archon. Like it's
it's starting to get pretty robust and
I'm able to build things with it that I
never could have or at least would have
taken many more prompts with something
like Windsor Cursor. So, I'm having a
blast with Archon and I've got a lot of
other plans for it as well that are
coming up soon here. So, you can check
out this GitHub repo if you want to go
through future iterations of Archon
things that I got coming up. One big
thing is including the Langraph
documentation as well as Pyantic AI.
There's already a pull request out for
this that I just needed to review. Um,
they did an awesome job, so I'm just
working on finishing up reviewing that.
But then Archon will be able to build
with both Pantic AI and Langraph. So,
really start to build sophisticated AI
agents. I can't wait for that. And then
one other one I want to call out really
quick. I don't want to cover all of
these right now, but another one that'll
be super cool is version 9, which this
will mean that Archon can literally not
just build the agent, but actually spin
up an isolated environment like create a
database and stuff and run the agent and
figure out, okay, is it working? Are
there any errors? Is it giving good
results? And then take all of that and
then autonomously refine the agent. So
just taking that uh self feedback loop
to the next level, actually running the
agent. So, so many awesome things that
I've got in store for Archon. I hope
that this can just be an awesome tool
for you to build your agents, learn more
advanced agentic systems cuz it is an
educational framework as well, like I
said earlier. So, yeah, I hope that you
just have a blast with this like I have
been having. And of course, let me know
in the comments if you have any
questions at all. I'm always open to
answering anything you're curious about.
So, I hope that this video clearly
showed you the power and potential of
Archon with an AI agent that you can use
right now and tweak to your own needs. I
mean, you can basically connect any MCP
server that you want to this AI agent
army. Also, I have a lot more coming up
for Archon with more content and more
features. So, stay tuned for that and
check out the GitHub page as well, which
I'll link to in the description if you
want to see my vision and the upcoming
features I want to implement. And I'd
also very much appreciate a star on the
GitHub repo as well. It means a lot to
me. So, if you appreciated this content
and you're looking forward to more
things Archon and AI agents, I would
really appreciate a like and a
subscribe. And with that, I'll see you
in the next